see you know right wait huh what what
buh-buh-buh going dead what so many hits
on that man
who Adam Sandler here this is kevin
garnett and we're about to start so hard
start cutting cutting bench bench is it
start bench cut start cut bench
you've heard us okay good luck
[Music]
somebody start the car two three but get
wretched I was like a classic - that's
like that's a diamond let's beat these
greatest work 2012 music hips okay call
me somebody that I used to know yeah I
know but I'd like to hear you say yeah
I'm starting call me maybe but midway
through the song I cut call me baby
and then I bench somebody
oh oh oh thank you Oh Paul would like
you to know you guys okay I got good
tender tender everything I'm starting
Serena then I'm just gonna politely ask
her do you mind if I put tonight here in
and she'll say yeah the tiger and then
then midway through tiger I'm gonna say
it's Brady time of you cool with that I
can't I'm not no one's getting cut
no one's getting benched three four
three let's see what happens
that's not even fair man you disrespect
Tiger right now no no no yes no lemo
I've cut and tiger no her all he's done
couldn't tightened you put him back in
there cutting time I'm giving you one
more chance but I'm cutting you dollar
you know why no I'm starring mama I call
sweetie grandma cause she's everybody's
mama and the lady I'm gonna put it on
put on the bench and you know come in
whoa all because throwing as many TVs
okay no more you know gunk ain't there
you know that means something yeah you
know the Brady's gonna figure it out
he's figuring it out as we speak
yes I'm Adam Sandler and I'm Kevin
Garnett you would listen you did such a
nice job at focusing on start cut bench
that we're gonna say go see our movie on
cut genzler right now what he said yes